hi I'm Barton Seaver chef and National
Geographic fellow and this is cook wise
in winemaking the concept of terroir of
how the earth of soil the air and the
sunshine add to the quality
characteristics of each individual one
is very important we're here in the iron
horse vendor it's discussing the idea of
marijuana in packed grape growing and
wine one of the unique qualities of iron
horse in our particular growing area
Green Valley is the fog we're defined by
the clock and the proximity to the ocean
the coolness being 13 miles as the crow
flies to the Pacific is directly related
to both the flavor and the quality of
our wines
these vines looking incredibly healthy I
never understood until I really started
studying why is it all grapes start have
green like this and and all the juice in
grapes is all white only from the skins
that you get the color obviously for red
wines and the flavor for red wines so
how would he one of these right now man
I wouldn't recommend it it's really
really really really yeah the worst
lemon you've ever been into now that is
the range of mountains that separates us
from Napa Valley this is the most
sought-after land right now in
California for Pinot Noir and Chardonnay
it's a combination of the Marine
influence that fog coming in that fog
leaving very cold nights warm not hot
days you want that fog especially during
harvest because what that does it
lengthens those nighttime temperatures
into the day and of course where this
once used to be an old Inland Sea so our
soils in this area are very sea lice
it's a sandy sandy loam soil very little
water holding capacity very low vigor a
perfect thing that you want for a
grapevine especially great friends like
Pinot Noir and Chardonnay so what do we
have in front of us here that's where
our sparkling wines go in those tirage
bins to bottle from it so when you walk
in that building down there it's like
the final scene in the first Indiana
Jones movie all you see is these wooden
bins and you kind of go where's the ark
treasure in here there's treasure and
you're actually there is treasure is
yeah we have about a hundred and twenty
pounds per square inch of pressure this
is cool
yes I was waiting for broken glass I
know I works and are you ready to start
the tasting yeah let's do it each one of
these bottles is actually the same wine
but with one last little difference each
one of these wines has a slightly
different dose ours at it to it it's a
special syrup that we make here and we
make several of them and so we have
various amounts of those syrups and each
one of these bottles to me food and wine
are completely inseparable anyway the
purpose of each other is to bounce
bounce mound take just tasting through
this I mean getting almost a hint of
cinnamon on this which I love a guy a
nice autumnal mussel dish with the
stewed tomatoes a little bit of cinnamon
garlic in there the muscles thrown in
and some white wine that is phase two of
this oh why are we working on let me
nice as soon as this is done the recipes
are taluk my favorite and I think what
represents the ocean best and what pairs
best with seafood I think maybe
something in the middle between three
and four a blend of these two would be
would be really killer there is so much
going on in this class there is history
geography geology chemistry art the
impact of the ocean as a super cool I am
so honored to propose the first toast
with the brand newly created ocean
reserve this is truly an honor
cheers to the oceans the ocean for
recipes tips techniques links seafood
stories and more visit ocean National
Geographic calm forward slash cook wise
for more about the ocean reserve cuvee
and to find out what you can do to help
protect the ocean visit I am the ocean
or and remember delicious is the new
environmentalism so cook wise